police in Bermuda are not ruling out
foul play in the mysterious death of an
American college student the body of 19
year old Mark Dombrowski was found on
the island yesterday
the freshman rugby player was last seen
early Sunday after his team competed in
a tournament teammates at st. Joseph's
University in Philadelphia gathered
yesterday to grieve and a Warner is at
the college campus in Philadelphia where
people are said to be shaken by their
loss and a good morning good morning
well mark Dombrowski left this campus
last week bound for Bermuda the plan was
for him to play for the first time ever
on the school's rugby sevens team there
but Sunday morning his family reported
him missing it was the day of his return
flight that set off a frantic search
that ended in tragedy we loved him
dearly we want him back Linda Dombrowski
had pleaded for her son's safe return
but Monday it became clear mark
Dombrowski would not be coming back
police found his body in a wooded area
near Fort Prospect a colonial-era
military garrison outside bermudez
capital Hamilton police have not yet
released any details about how the 19
year old died foul play is not ruled out
right now the forensic officers are
there they're assessing the scene
assessing the body Dombrowski played on
the st. Joseph's varsity rugby team and
was in Bermuda for a tournament
investigators say Saturday night after
their final game he and his teammates
went to a bar in Hamilton called the dog
house there's no information to suggest
at the moment that he himself was
intoxicated or that alcohol is a part
police say Dombrowski left the bar
shortly after midnight Sunday at 1:09
a.m. a security camera spotted him about
four blocks away alone and using his
cell phone he showed up in another
surveillance video about six minutes
later the site where his body was found
is near Bermudas police headquarters as
well as the Sports Center where the
rugby tournament was held we expect an
autopsy to be carried out in due course
we spoke with some of his friends last
night at the memorial service at a
church near here and they remembered a
young man John full of energy and
promise and one who will be sorely
missed you know thanks